will ferrell and zach galifianakis both
who had roots in north carolina and some
connection to political stuff sacks
uncle had run for US Senate against
Jesse Helms he had been a congressman
and they wanted to be in a movie
together where they would go against
each other and they decided politics so
they give a came to me and said would
you would you direct this an adam mckay
who's worked with will on the bush thing
the HBO thing and the show they did was
going to write it with chris henchy and
i'm producing also those are the Funny
or Die guys so I just said yeah sure I'm
happy to jump in and that's they came to
me I think because I had done to
political films recently game change and
recount for HBO and I'd also done comedy
and worked with will i think i think i
was in Wills i think i think i was i did
wills first feature film because he was
in austin powers as a mustafa the
assassin that you couldn't quite kill
off and I'd work with Zack to and
Jennifer schmuck so they each come at
you a different way will is seems so
accessible and you can you feel like you
kind of get him and then there's layers
of dysfunction that come out throughout
their right course the story whereas
zach is off-putting from the get-go he's
one of the he just seems like one of the
weirdest people ever when you first you
know meet him on screen and often in
real life too he's very he's a very
funny eccentric person and but as you
get to know the character I feel he he
is becomes the heart and soul of the
story and you kind of fall for him
because you see how sweet he is in a way
as it goes on and that's kind of how
they come out that's how they are to
work with to it takes a while it took a
while for me to get sacks kind of rhythm
but then once once I did he snuck up on
me too and it was an amazing experience
and there they are there they're very
close but they a lot of times you have
trouble with actors absorbing each
others energy and they start to seem
like the same character
not with these two guys there they they
always even off-camera when they're
kidding each other and they're often
trash-talking each other off camera two
they they retain complete separation
they're very distinct and separate from
each other which is made it easy for me
we were shooting during the GOP
primaries which had a feeling of reality
show competition at a time just that
their primary season happened to be
going on right we're so every day we
would come in and say did you did you
see what happened yesterday do you see
what someone said the night before and
we would often say we got to step this
up and try to work something and to the
remember one story just briefly was that
it was announced that Herman Cain had
been accused of some kind of sexual
harassment thing and the next week is
polls went up so we fold the debt into
the script right away but we always
wanted to have it by my parents are very
very conservative like super
conservative and they I have them on my
shoulder well you know like and they're
they're quick to adjust you know me in
terms of my prejudices you know about
about certain aspects of things that we
don't we don't always agree on
everything but I want them to find
something in it that that they can't
dismiss you know so I often even on in
Game Change when when we were you know
my dad sent me a note saying now you
don't go there from Texas so I can
imitate their southern accent you don't
go messing with Sara making fun of Sarah
so I you know I had that in mind I
wanted people to like my father to get
something about what we were saying
about what was wrong with that kind of
win at all costs rushed vet kind of
thing and and but still be very you know
honest and truthful about exactly what
was flawed and dysfunctional about that
situation so here we is a comedy first
and foremost we weren't trying to make
any kind of propaganda piece except to
just say wow is this this is really how
we want politics to go because it isn't
that far from it's almost a documentary
what's going on is one tricky thing was
we want because if we couldn't have it
be too big of a budget based on the kind
of movie it was
finding the right state we wanted to
shoot in North Carolina and we had all
heard that that was a tax break
statement and it turns out the Louisiana
tax break was much much better and then
for whatever reason I there there was
North Carolina wasn't practical so we
ended up having to shoot in one of the
most striking beautiful cities you know
there is and make it look like an
entirely different place that was a that
was always a challenge because we ended
up shooting in more of the suburbs than
in in this city but but man the food is
amazing all people talked about around
the monitors was what restaurant they
and I was that became one of the hardest
challenges but no no we're actually
shooting you know I don't want to hear
about the beef cheeks you had it
Sylvain's last night